Ross and I recently got the privilege
to meet a remarkable and incredible group of women.
It's as, you know, amazing as it gets.
They just made history as the first women ever
to be in the pit crew at the Daytona 500.
(audience cheering wildly)
Take a look.
Please welcome Breanna O'Leary, Bree Daniels,
and Dalanda Ouendeno.
Hi.
(audience clapping)
Hey.
Hi.
Hello, hello.
Hey, what's going on?
Oh my gosh, we're so excited to meet you.
Bree, you broke a barrier.
You are the first black woman to change tires in NASCAR.
Is that true?
Yes, ma'am.
Wow.
(audience clapping)
Yes.
How fast can you do it?
And how did you get so good at it?
I would say I'm pretty fast.
One tire is coming off in less than a second,
if not, you know, a second at the most,
and a whole pitstop is done
between like 11 and 13 seconds max.
Whoa. So cool.
And Breanna with Bree, you guys,
you both made history as the first female duo
to ever pit in the Daytona 500, isn't that right?
Yeah, that was us.
That's amazing. Look at that.
(audience cheering)
A duo.
How does it feel?
It was really empowering, just because me and Brehanna
came into the program together.
Essentially from day one, me and her were together,
learning everything.
So to see the fruits of our labor in such a big stage
of the Daytona 500, was just so empowering
and so much fun and we just couldn't believe it.
And so we just tried to enjoy it the best we could.
Now, Dalanda, you were a soccer champion,
and now the first woman from outside of the US to pit,
is that true?
Yes, yes. That's true.
Well-
I played the soccer-
(audience cheering)
Where were you playing soccer?
Paris St. Germaine in France for PSG,
and then I got recruited to play D1 in the US
for the University of Miami.
I mean, can I ask each and every one of you,
why you got into what you got into
and what makes you happy about it?
Bree, why did you get into this,
and what does it feed you?
To be honest, I was playing basketball
at Norfolk State University,
and I've learned that, once I joined the sport,
not too many of us are doing it, not too many women.
And, I'm just saying that somebody has to set the tone,
to be that example for other women
to want to be able to join a sport,
with barely any women in there.
So, yeah.
Cool.
Thanks to you.
You are changing that.
(audience clapping)
Love that.
Breanna, why did you get into this
and what does it feed you?
This opportunity from the Drive for Diversity program
happened to come by my university.
And it was, it was kind of like a why not?
It wasn't, I didn't know what I was getting myself into
but I just thought why not?
And it turns out in the whole, grand scheme of things
probably the most rewarding part of all of it
is getting to hear that I'm an inspiration
or that little girls now know
that they can go change tires if they want to.
And so that's definitely been the coolest part
of all of this.
I look at that picture of you in the crowd
on the rail, just soaking it in.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
And Dalanda, why did you decide to do this?
And how does it feed you?
I just wanted to have fun.
I joined NASCAR just to see what was around.
It was a new experience.
I was like, why not?
And just going to bed at night,
knowing that you're badass, is just so gratifying.
(audience cheering)
Yes. It does.
Yes, yes.
Yes it does, and you all are.
That is the best.
And I'm so grateful that you would come here
and tell your stories, and we can see you and hear you
and celebrate you as we do.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)